hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
heute euch in einer instagram story
gefragt ob ihr mir nicht mal einige
stuhl fällt von euch zu senden könnt was
habt ihr zahlreich gemacht und ich würze
angefangen mit diesem hier bei mir in
der schule ist nichts lustig
interessiert keinen
ich gehe dann habe man im unterricht
gefurzt und es auf meine banknachbarin
geschoben
geht ja echt richtig in der schule bei
der lehrerinnen sind kaká macht das
bitte in dem video mit rein
kann man irgendwie seine community
tauschen oder so ich habe mal fast in
die hose gekauft weil meine lehrerin
mich nicht aufs klo gelassen hat
warum war
vom normalen job wollte meine mädchen
kleber auf den stuhl kleben und habe
mich selber drauf gesetzt
war mal auf schulklo und da kam ein
lehrer rein und hat es seien draussen
hat irgendwer von euch das thema lustige
schulfests verstanden ist der fläche der
beiden parallelogramm gleich groß er
dann jahren gekreuzt und die begründung
seiner antwort ist ist halt so
[Applaus]
also ich euer lehrer wären dann will ich
ganz schnell nicht mehr lehrer sein
wollen wir haben im sportunterricht zu
einem vertrauen spiel mit augen zu
gespielt und ich bin irgendwie
losgerannt weil ich es lustig fand und
bin dann in den wald reinen gerannt
hatte nasenbluten und eine beule
so
frag mich wie ihr überhaupt es
nicht zu atmen hier sollte jemand eine
werte tabelle zeichnen und er hat
einfach das hier gezeichnet bruder
das ist einfach eine banane die tanzt
ist jetzt kein lustiger fail aber ich
wollte einfach mal mit meinem latein
vokabeltests flexen weil das ist das
einzig krasse was ich je in meinem leben
erreicht haben dann können dann schickt
sie mir als ihren vokabeltest und den
habe ich mir allerdings einmal genauer
angeguckt
und man sieht einfach dass der kopiert
ist und oben rechts sieht man sogar noch
die website und oben links die
pixelgröße mit der sie das kopiert hat
also nicht mal eine gute note faken kann
meine community aufgabe fünf wenn anne
durch ein mikroskop schaut kann sie
trotz fluoreszenz ist die nadel haben
sie trotz fluoreszierenden farbstoff auf
der zellmembran nichts erkennen woran
könnte das liegen sie ist blind
also
ich also ich kann
in der schule früher habe ich auf einmal
so laut gefurzt und das auch noch in
klasse deine mutter kaufte er eine jacke
für 70 euro und eine hose für 90 euro
was ergibt dass streit mit meinem vater
robert hat 50 kekse er ist 35 davon auf
was hat er dann einen besuch im
krankenhaus ja
mein wenigstens sind das richtige
schulfeste nicht so wie das sie jetzt
zum beispiel mein schüler fällt er mir
gerade so spontan einfällt es war
mottowoche der dreizehner und asi tag
ich in der elften klasse hatte zufällig
auch die jogginghose oder leggings an
fragt ein lehrer mich ob ich auch beim
motto mitmache oder ob das mein look ist
selten so gut gefühlt apropos mottowoche
keine ahnung wer mich da verarscht hat
aber das war der baby tag das buch ist
übrigens an meinem arm und ich über mein
leben geschrieben und diesen pool das
achtklässler wissen wie physik
geschrieben wird und sie schreiben
physik sammer
sagte einfach nichts
sagt einfach nichts in der ersten
kameraden von mir 'nen zahn ausgefallen
sein bester freund war da neidisch auf
ihn fragt mich nicht warum haha und hat
sich dann einen schneidezahn
rausgerissen der war halt nur keinen
milchzahn mehr und dann hat er ein
ersatz bekommen hh
den aufbau einer seifenblase und sie
zeichnet einfach ein kreis wenn ich euch
mit einem gemüse vergleichen würde ich
glaube ihr wert sonne verschimmelte
zucchini
man mag zucchinis eigentlich schon nicht
aber wenn sie verschimmelt ist dann ist
halt noch mal schlimmer ich habe meine
note von vier auf zwei gehandelt weil
ich gesagt habe ich war doch leider als
meine freundin fast leider als warum
mache ich das hier wie wird milch
hergestellt da muss man die kuh fragen
und warum gibt eine kuh milch weil sie
ihre kinder versorgen muss scheiß auf
biologie einfach mit der kugel ein
freund und ich haben eine halbe stunde
bevor die erste stunde anfing mit
unserem haus schon gegen den
lichtschalter geschossen um das licht
auszumachen ich frage mich jetzt schon
dass die chance hier soll ich habe es
dann auch geschafft doch dann war der
lichtschalter kaputt und das licht ging
nur manchmal an und keiner wusste warum
das licht nicht mehr anging
ja es war im abschluss hier muss jemand
die frage was bedeutet m ü.nn
beantworten und er schreibt meter über
meeresspiegel in klammern meter über
normalnull also dass es richtig gewesen
die andere frage ist allerdings was
bedeutet in der karten legende das
symbol richtig bahngleise dann
bundesstraße auch richtig dann mischwald
der verschiedenen teile da auch richtig
und das ist ja
wlan nicht so viel zu tun bei uns sind
zwei jungs mit dem tisch für den
tageslichtprojektor eine wand gefahren
und dann war ein loch in
dann war ein loch in dieser wand welches
sie versucht haben mit zwei din a 4
blättern abzudecken damit die lehrer es
nicht kommen bei mir in der klasse haben
zwei schüler einen schüler als rammbock
benutzt um die wand kaputt zu machen
danach war ein loch in der wand in
klammern sie haben den schüler mit den
beinen in die wand gehauen nicht mit dem
kopf
irgendwas verpasst hier sollte
teile einer note beschreiben und das
macht er noch richtig das ist nämlich
der noten hals das unteren ende
allerdings nur deko
[Musik]
fällt mir doch nichts mehr zu einem
kommen wir nun allerdings zur ersten
frage eines napoleon crysis und zwar
wurde napoleon geboren bei seiner mutter
und was war sein beruf offizier
beziehungsweise general das war dann
richtig allerdings wie alt war er denn
als die französische revolution begann
alt genug schreibt man in die kommentare
in diesem video bisher geklatscht haben
bewusst hat der lehrer mal ein test
gemacht wo man kein name hin schreibt
und erteilt die dann haus nur an der
handschrift ich habe es bekommen war
nicht meine habe gesagt war meiner und
hatte eine 1 der lehrer bestimmt ja auch
geglaubt bei deiner rechtschreibung der
hat mir ein schüler regeln geschickt die
er missachtet hat uns zwar einmal drei
sekunden zu spät im mathe unterricht und
das muss ein richtiger ahlmann lehrer
gewesen sein
zu guter letzt haben wir allerdings ein
zeugnis eines schülers aus frankfurt und
wir fangen jetzt mal ganz oben an jetzt
geboren am 11
2000 das bestimmt überhaupt nicht fähig
und das zeugnis handelt vom schuljahr
2016/17 und zweiten halbjahr versäumte
unterrichtstage keine ja davon
unentschuldigte hab doch geschrieben
keine
kombi nun allerdings zu seinen nothin
und zwar schon deutsch marschall matte -
englisch ist gute musik gute biologie
und chemie sehr ausreichend geschichte
kann er gut und musik auch sehr nice
geografie hotspot salto ist religion
moslem kunst der es model normal und
kunde übertrieben sehr gut machen wir
weiter mit der teilnahme an ags
praktikas und projekten hat das kunde
praktikum mit bravour absolviert
lehrerin war mehr als befriedigt
und in den bemerkungen unten steht der
schüler bereichert den unterricht mit
seinem humor seine streiche sind laut
kick und er kennt alle nummern von
auswendig wenn ihr noch kein abonnent
von meinem kanalseite dann lasst es
besser auch
[Musik]